okay  do you feel like you give girls more  wiggle room if they're if they're hotter  yes  you have do you know what is you have to  be real with yourself though like you  gotta you gotta look yourself in the  mirror so if someone's taking a piece  you're gonna be like come on man and I  think that's where people say it's ego  but that's where you gotta kind of  release say to yourself that's why if  you set yourself like those morals and  those ground rules for yourself then no  matter who steps in front of you if they  disrespect you then they disrespect you  you gotta kind of hold yourself  accountable to them but do they get away  with a bit more be honest uh than if she  was average if if it's black and white  then no